让自己变得牛逼越来越强大的方法是
去做那些红又到你不可能失败的事
大家一定做不懂事
我要家庭决心有做什么事
努力了
然后你坚持了一个离拜
这个离拜你的热情是非常高党的
第二个离拜你的热情还是下降
然后比3个离拜
比4个离拜
然后这个事就不来遥知了
我呢
给他车两个牛茶
牛吧
这不是人
有不算帅对吧
你认识一下
我呢拍出过
好多个地方
上千万不放的本视频
怎么做到
一会告诉你方法
那我呢曾经写过这么一后的一会说
这不是超后的
好多人
等下想被日子带他去的特别后
但是我写这本时候几乎不是不费利的
我是怎么做到的
我当然可以给你去中节
好说说一个我是怎么还出上千万播放的这个视频大
第一步第二步第三步的速度
但是事实的真相是
如果真是这样的话
那我应该每条视频都是上千万播放的
对吧
那为什么现在我真的情况是每天
平时的播放量是几十万上百万而不是上千万
我告诉你真正的原因是我每天都会派一条视频
写出一本书的真正的原因是什么
是每天我都会写点什么东西
所以大家有些你可以看那个书上纯术
他先这个奴格的算ings的时候是什么
我看面不是去当灵感
因为有的时候你是没有灵感的
那怎么办呢
每天至少写一些东西
为什么会这个样子
各位
让你发生改变的
是那些小道你一定可以完成的事
因为这样的话你就是你要想做一个事的时候
你特别容易的时候这个大脑是抗局的
你就要靠一直力不端的靠一直力
一直力做了消耗就没了
但是如果是很小的一样是那不切的一样小事的话呢
这个大脑的防御总就没有起来
而且你越做做的做的做的做
就变成了一种一种习惯
行动
不是动机的结果
行动是动机的成因
然后你做的越多
你们满足会有一种
身份的人同着我做这个事不是因为习惯不是我要做哪个事
我就会这样的人呢
你为什么每天写一种
我是个搜一下呀
我当然每天要写的东西了
你为什么每天要拍到视频呢
我是个阿富族啊我当然每天要拍到视频了
我我是这样的人所以我要做这样的事
每天看的还能很多不起啊
但是你知道改变等于
天数
成于可重复
今天轨一点很小的学校
明天去习惯后天去习惯慢慢就会变成一个很大的学校
那具体该怎么做呢
首先第一步你要学会用鸡鸭糕的方式我把他叫鸡鸭糕啊
就你每天在忙你也要起出一点鸭糕来
比如说我想亲身每天做一个服势
我每天读书每天读一夜吃
而且然后我想去学认语每天被一个单次
我想写会说每天写鸡鸭糕
就做一个很小很小的事情
然后这个事的话最好复在一个习惯之后
什么意思比如说每天都要刷牙刷牙的时候把做个生育
我每天都要上位声音啊这个有点问啊
我去看一一只
我想做鸭鸭糕啊咱们呢
不是一事来做一个小什么影响是我每天睡觉之前做五分钟的影响
他不会启动防律懂他这很自然感觉连在后面当你做的多的时候
他就会变成习惯
然后中习惯做的生成就会参成最大的复理效应
所以我也
让自己真正发生改变的方法不是下很新下决心分发主强
而是每天去做一件小道你不可能玩不成的
是
行动
不是动机的结果他是动机的
承认
而最终的结果
取决于天数
承许
扩重无复